it is a couple of minutes to 1800 gmt 7
58 p.m in paris hello i'm nick clark and
we're beginning this newshour slightly
early to bring you al jazeera's special
coverage of the french presidential
election final ballots are being cast
and very shortly we'll have estimated
results voters choosing whether to
re-elect president emmanuel macron or go
with his challenger marine le pen leader
of the far-right national rally party
let's cross straight away to paris
natasha butler is standing by and
natasha estimated results are imminent
they are imminent and i'm going to keep
looking down just to see whether or not
i get them and i can read them out to
you
this basically brings to an end the past
two weeks in which we have seen emmanuel
macron the uh centrist centrist
incumbent he is looking for a second
term uh campaign very hard indeed as has
uh his rival the far-right uh leader
marine le pen both have been trying to
persuade undecided voters to go out and
vote they've also been trying to
persuade many uh voters on the left to
go out and vote for them because there
hasn't been a natural candidate for
left-wing voters but we know the
millions uh picked the far left leader
jean-luc bellocho in the first round so
those voters have been seen as being
very much up for grabs if you like by
both uh macro and le pen we've seen
rallies we've seen them going around
markets trying to present their vision
to the people and they are two very
different visions indeed emanuel macron
pro-eu he is someone who wants to
continue he says with his reformist in
agenda he is a believer in
multilateralism on the other hand marine
le pen who is going for a third shot at
the elise say she very much hopes to
become france's first woman president
she also hopes to become the first uh
far-right president in the elysee she is
anti-eu she's anti-immigration she says
that if elected she would launch a
referendum on national identity in
france she would also ban uh muslim
women from being able to wear a
headscarf in public i'm just going to
look down to see if we've got the
results and i believe they might have
come in what i'm seeing is
emmanuel macron on
58.2 percent
marine le pen on
41.8 so 58.2
for emmanuel macron and marine le pen
41.8 percent emmanuel macron is france's
next president for the next five years
so to joining us now with a bit of
reaction is pierre husky he's a
political commentator here in france and
a veteran analyst of these things
emmanuel macron he has another five
years 58 was your reaction well first of
all we expected him to win but not with
such a high margin i think he he must be
pretty uh satisfied with this figure
because uh his followers were
fearing uh below 55
a very narrow gap with marine le pen
would have been dangerous for the next
few years because
the country would have been split almost
in two
58 is really a good margin for him and
it shows that he has managed he entered
the campaign very late
people were dismayed that he had
such a low rating of campaign but during
the between the two rounds of the
election he really campaigned hard and
he managed to get a a fair section of
the left-wing voters to block marine le
pen not to support him because a lot of
them
don't like macron's policies but they
would they didn't want to see 9 le pen
in the elysee that's going to be a
problem for him though isn't it the next
five years because he knows that so many
people didn't vote for him that they did
vote to block marine pen how is he going
to
manage that and how is he going to also
manage the fact that we had more than a
quarter of french people who decided
simply not to vote at all is he
legitimate many people will raise the
issue of legitimacy because
as you said they didn't vote for his
program
or the
abstain but we're going to have a test
very soon we have legislative elections
for parliament
in june only in two months time and
that's going to be
determining the future of france because
if emmanuel macron doesn't get the
majority he will have to have what we
call in france cohabitation that means
living together with a government from a
different uh majority
and that's we've had that in the past
and jack shirak had a
also had a cooperation with the
socialist prime minister but that would
be quite unprecedented and for the
legislative elections you'll have to
count also with milan charles voters the
the far left so
the game is back uh
to the center and and we're entering a
new phase of the political life that's
going to be quite determining
manuel macron he's 44 years old he was
just 39 in 2017 when he uh won back then
he is a young leader he's often seen as
dynamic he's also made history in a way
tonight because it's the first time that
we've had a french president re-elected
for uh two decades i also imagine that
there'll be quite a few people in
brussels in the european union that
might be breathing a sigh of relief that
it is him that has won and not marine le
pen definitely i think europe
could not afford another crisis
provoked by the election of marine le
pen because her program
is anti-eu it would have paralyzed the
european union and don't forget that
france is still
cheering the european union for another
two months
so
she would have been uh the the
chairwoman of the european union uh next
week which would have been a really
very tough in in this time of the
ukraine crisis uh she had also had in
their program to leave the military wing
of nato
which was a big scare for for many
leaders so
europe is definitely relieved today uh
not another crisis on its arms
we have to talk about marine le pen of
course this is
was her third shot at the elysee she
wanted to be present for a third time
she has failed in this
why do you think that she failed to
capture the imagination of voters what
what is it that she didn't manage to do
i think there are two reasons one
first of all we have to recognize that
she did a better score than in 2017
not as good as she might have been
hoping for but it's still an increase on
her
previous score but she has two handicaps
one is that
she's from the far right and and and
there's still this glass ceiling the far
right is is still unable to come to
power in frost and i think a majority of
the people are still
reluctant to let that happen and and
secondly
there was this credibility gap that she
failed to to cover in 2017 during her
debate with emmanuel macron it was a big
failure for her and everybody was
expecting
this year's debate which happened last
week and
she didn't perform so well she was she
had trained she had
rehearsed
but emmanuel macron is a good expert on
those issues he knows every every single
issue by heart and and she was
struggling to be at his level and i
think she still hasn't reached the level
where a majority of the people would
trust her even though she softened her
image very much over the
last few years i mean they didn't change
her agenda which as you say was a very
far right anti-immigration uh banning
the the veil for muslim women in public
those sorts of things but she did very
much try to soften her image tried to
change to appeal to more people in
france she she had an advantage during
the first round is that there was a a
candidate that was even more extreme
than her eric zemuau and and he took all
the
delight for the extreme ideas
particularly on immigration on islam on
those issues and and suddenly after the
second round she was on the first row
and she
couldn't manage to keep that soft image
that she had built over the years uh
suddenly the most controversial issues
whether it's uh the veil for women for
muslim women or her links to vladimir
putin came to the forefront and were
really uh in the debate with emmanuel
macron really the the the toughest
moments
and she didn't win that argument what do
you think about the fact that emmanuel
macron
internationally
is often seen as a leader in a positive
light people he often is praised
internationally for his efforts on the
international stage diplomacy yet in
france so many people seem to dislike
him now he's won this election of course
because some people are supporting him
some people have voted against le pen
nevertheless he has something of an
image problem in france doesn't he he
has he has he's seen as
arrogant to be uh to to make it in one
word there were many instances in the
first in the past five years during his
first mandate where he had these short
sentences his attitudes uh towards um
poor people or marginal people that were
seen as social arrogance and he's seen
as
representative of the successful frost
you know and our society like
most western societies today is really
split into between the insiders and
outsiders we had that in the us with uh
trump we had that with brexit in in the
uk
and that's the case in france and and
emmanuel macron maybe to to the
caricature
is
personifies uh this successful france
that is looking down on the unsuccessful
one and that has really been hard for
him uh to get rid of that image
and in the next five years it's going to
be challenging also for him isn't it
because he is going to want to press
ahead with some reform some of them
controversial he wants to
change the age of retirement here in
france for example a lot of people
haven't liked that
it's not necessarily going to be an easy
five years ahead is it particularly as
you say you've got parliamentary
elections coming up he may not have a
majority what do you think we might
expect in the next five years he knows i
think that he's going to go to have a
rough five years it's going to be a
rough ride because
his legitimacy will be questioned every
time he wants to make a major choice for
the country
and maybe the first test will be the
retirement age because that has been the
most controversial issue proposal of his
program to postpone
to 65 the the retirement age and and so
he's he's going to have to show skills
to negotiate with the unions to
to give this impression that it's a fair
reform and not an unjust reform uh for
the the poorest and and those who have
worked hard so uh it's going to get gets
is he will have to govern on the left
more than he's done
until now that's the only chance he has
to uh survive in in that period but
that's going to uh ask him a lot of uh
um thinking against himself
we're talking about mackerel we've
talked about le pen but you know one of
the other big themes of this election
has been the disappearance of the main
political parties that for so long
dominated the french political landscape
the socialist candidate in order to be
seen the conservative candidate nowhere
to be seen
do we think that might change
in the future
well the both parties the on the right
and on the left have
local
leaders local mayors presidents of
regents and so on so they they have
disappeared on the national level they
have not totally disappeared on the
local level so the question for them is
whether they can
revive their
national ambitions and programs and
appeal
or if they will also disappear on the
local level so the legislative elections
will be
in a way the ultimate test for them if
they fail that test if they disappear
from parliament they are doomed all
right pierre husky thank you very much
indeed for joining me to talk about
those election results uh here in paris
as we have told you emmanuel macron the
centrist incumbent no longer incumbent i
should say because he is now the
president of france the next five years
marine le pen uh having lost this
election it was her third run at the
elysee but this time it wasn't for her
the french have chosen uh mackerel back
to you natasha fantastic thanks very
much indeed for that uh from paris and
just to recap once again the polling
agencies have projected a 44 year old
president macron winning a second term
defeating far-right rival marine le pen
uh he will be the first french president
since jack shirak in 2002 to secure a
second term and here's an interesting
fact as we look at the podium where
macron will appear at some point uh to
give his victory speech uh the
interesting fact is that shirak was
massively helped by being up against
marine le pen's father jean-marie whom
he defeated in a landslide and that was
back in 2002. let's bring in al
jazeera's senior political analyst
marwyn bashara who joins us also from
paris and mar and in the event
a decisive second round for macron
well 58 is certainly better than 52
or 51 as many of the polls were
expecting him to get
so certainly there's the sigh of relief
in the elysee just like there's a sigh
of relief
in europe in the west in general i would
say in washington in brussels there's
definitely a deep deep sigh of relief
that the centrist
incumbent
has won the elections by this sort of a
margin it is not as high as the last
time around in 2017
but clearly high enough for him
to claim that he has a mandate and for
the centrist parties or centrist
coalitions in various capitals in europe
to claim that once again they were able
to box in
the radical right
well at least until the next round of
elections
now some would of course uh you know say
that well he got 28 in the first round
58 in the second round that means he got
more than
uh double uh of what he got in the first
round
and that double that 30 percent extra
has come from various parties in the
center right and center left as well as
and especially uh from the far left from
the milongshon
uh
uh crowd and hence i think he will be
asked once again to take his mandate
not to be a hundred percent for his own
ideas and agenda
but that of those who supported him and
the political parties that
voiced uh their support for him from the
uh from the very first hours uh of of of
monday the 11th
and hence it remains to be seen whether
really uh president macron will take the
mandate to be a bit more inclusive
representing more and more of the french
as he sort of alluded to when he spoke
about few of the controversial issues
and programs that he had in mind
he starts straight away doesn't he so
it's in that sense you know as opposed
to being a new incumbent if you like
he's he's got a second term so he has a
difficult second mandate there's going
to be little or no grace period as he
gets stuck into his agenda
but this is the thing you see i mean on
the one hand he can claim to be
a historical president
a transformative president because this
is the first time since uh the goal back
in 58 where a president
with a majority in parliament is able to
get a second mandate so not only did he
win the second mandate since iraq 2002.
it's the first time in 40 50 years that
a president wins a second term while
having a majority hence he could say
look you know i'm making history here in
the country
and on the other hand if it weren't for
the total collapse of the center-right
and the center-left parties the
socialists and the republicans he
wouldn't have gotten this sort of i'm
just going to jump in there because not
just
just making a statement uh in defeat
let's have a listen
strong power something that is different
to that of emmanuel macron
faced with their
threats their purchasing power
public
services and the social system
faced with the withdrawal
faced with insecurity of immigration
and the judicial system indeed
i fear tonight
that
people will not
emmanuel macron will not do anything
to deal with what is dividing our
country and our compatriots
so to avoid
this more than ever i will pursue my
work for the french people with energy
perseverance
and the affection that you know
following
these presidential elections there'll be
a great political
movement with the dominant
parties faced with the elites of
emmanuel macron
and the true we are the true opposition
because in a few weeks
we will have the parliamentary elections
with the voting
system we have which strengths and
things that they are parliamentary
representativity
will be show
and manufacture having all the
legislative
presidential power which cannot be
acceptable
for
france
so those who claim tomorrow to be the
opposition it will continue to re-elect
him
we will be
those with sincerity
will be with your interests as a result
we see the great electoral battle for
the parliamentary elections coming
forward
i will carry out this battle
with all of those who have the courage
to oppose emmanuel macron with all those
have the nation in their heart
to unite
all those who come together who want to
unite their strengths
to
present or support candidates everywhere
and in your constituency
and abroad and in all the constituencies
abroad already to support them with all
your strength from the 12th of june
remind yourselves dear friends there's
nothing is predestined we must continue
to keep
hope and give us the means to defend
them the historical score of tonight
puts us in a an excellent position to
have a large number of deputies in june
with the future that enlivens us with
the greatest ambitions the only ambition
which is worth considering and that is
of france tonight
i'm saying it again
never will i abandon the french people
long live the republic long live france
ah
[Applause]
that is marie le pen of the national
rally party conceding defeat
uh now saying that she fears that
tonight emmanuel macron will not do
anything to deal with what is dividing
our country she says she will continue
her work
parliamentary elections are coming up
the match is not yet over she says
saying that uh that great electoral
battle is coming up in june and she will
fight it for with all she's got let's go
back tomorrow and bashara who's been
listening in
marvin what are your thoughts about
marine le pen now is it game over for
her
well no no absolutely not uh nick
although she does sound a bit bitter
rather angry and vengeful
there were no kind words uh for her uh
uh for her competitor
you know you would expect in such
circumstance for her to be giving a bit
of congratulations a bit you know the
french have spoken
and after all she did get few uh
percentage points more than the last
time but no i think she is already
preparing for the legislative elections
she's rallying the troops this is a call
for arms political arms of course in
order to organize for the legislative
elections because i think both her and
those on the far left are already
juxtapositioning in order to gain as
much uh seats as possible in the
legislature in order for him to have the
so-called cohabitation in order for them
to be able to rule along with uh the
president but yes as to your uh
i think indispensable question looking
forward i think from her father in 2002
to her record in 2017 and now getting 42
in this election i think if i were uh
you know uh one of those uh leading
positions in europe i would be worried
about the next elections
because clearly the radical right is on
the ascendance in france and elsewhere
and if they didn't win next this time
well we never know what's going to
happen next and that's why president
macron the way he leads
in the next five years is going to be
key because he can only serve two terms
and what happens after that with the
center right and the center left being
in such total collapse
one would worry about the future of
france now having said that i just want
to add one more thing because i kept an
eye on social media as we were listening
to marine le pen i just want to tell our
viewers around the world
that the 40 plus percent that voted for
marine le pen are not racist french
they are not new fascists
you know people vote for different
reasons in france
and they don't all have their hand or
their finger on the pulse of the racist
and racist that in every single thing
that marie lupin
said or did or want to do a lot of
french people vote because they are
desperate because they are unhappy
because they are bitter because they
lost their jobs because they've tried
the center left the center right and
this and the liberal macro and they
don't find solutions and they say look
we've tried everything we might as well
try lupine
so people vote for different reasons in
this country like people in england for
example voted for brexit it's not
because they are racist it's because
they have things on their mind and i
think europe
and france in particular
is in a bit of a malaise
there is a crisis going on in the
country economic social political and so
on and so forth and hence
at times a good number of people are
voting randomly in order just to see
what could come up perhaps something
better next time around
all right marwan leave it there for the
moment thanks for that moment bashar
there in paris let's bring in natasha
butler who's also standing by for us in
paris and natasha we heard from marine
le pen they're rallying supporters uh
for the upcoming parliamentary elections
and straight of work for macron to try
and have a good result out of those as
well
yes marine le pen talking about the
parliamentary elections she's already
looking ahead to what some people in
france call the third round if you like
a moment where people then uh have to
choose the makeup of the parliament and
that will determine how much uh power
france's uh ongoing president new
president emmanuel macron actually has
marine le pen also saying that uh the
win for macron uh was going to be
divisive for france was going to be uh
destructive for france as well the
things you would expect her to say she
had no kind words for uh her rival i'd
like to bring in now nicola vegborg he
is a professor at sorbonne university
here in paris nicolas thank you very
much indeed uh for joining us first of
all i'd like your reaction to these
results emmanuel macron 58
marine le pen 41
well uh further
it's already a good thing that there is
a clear decision on uh for this election
a narrow margin would have been quite
difficult to manage the result is
much less
than uh five years before which means
that definitely there is some kind of
unpopularity of macon and regarding his
policy especially
the result outside of metropole i mean
we had some uh clues from the utromer
was really really positive for lupin
which france's overseas territories yes
and that revealed that there's
definitely a gap within the french
population because even though the they
were not largely uh important debates or
even though you had no large programs
definitely there are two visions of
france which were challenging there one
or i would say open-minded or at least
uh which fits with globalization the
other one which is to retreat on the
front within the frontier and
what she named national uh national
preference even though that's quite
difficult to explain exactly what it
means
so definitely you have two visions of
societies and when you get into results
in the days to come it will be even more
revealing and afraid so of a real
division between the let's say
urban young society and more traditional
one and that makes it quite difficult to
figure exactly what will happen uh in
two months from now because as you as
you mentioned she's already running for
the legislative the parliamentarians
and as you may remember uh parliament is
quite powerful at least uh in time of uh
opposition when the the stronger
position were
what's up what was quite surprising
when you are the prime minister from a
different side than the president and we
realized that finally the prime minister
is a bit more powerful than the
president himself
that the difficulty in the ambiguity of
the fifth republic
because emmanuel macron for the last
five years had uh
his party had a majority in the
parliament so that gave him a lot of
power and what we're seeing now is if
that shifts if that changes if he
doesn't manage to have a majority in
these uh june parliamentary elections
it's going to make life a lot more
difficult for him and not only that he
knows that many people simply didn't
vote for him or only voted for him in
order not to vote for marine le pen yeah
the last time we were twice we had that
situation at least with jacques shirak
in front of jean-marie le pen then five
years ago each time the president
claimed the electoral president claimed
that he would understand that everybody
was not voting for his program but
against le pen and son and son but
nevertheless he did whatever he wanted
because he had a strong majority
this time we have to fail the situation
with a party which is quite young in
fact five years five years young which
is not summer tradition which is quite
interrogated with people who are coming
from the left people who are coming from
the civil society or the ones who are
quite conservative
people seem to be more unsatisfied with
the current policy it
well we'll see traditionally the
president to win the election with the
parliamentary election and as
a way of margin this time it might be
more difficult for macron and it would
might need to work with a coalition
which brings back more to the fourth
republic than to the fifth republic
that's something which will be very very
new and will figure exactly how
political macron is in fact
macro
presents himself he's considered a
centrist candidate but over the last
five years many have said he has moved
more to the right with some of his
policies on security on immigration
things like that he has had though to
try and attract voters from the left
over the past few weeks to vote for him
in order to win this presidency do you
think we might see a shift in some of
his policy and some of his agenda to the
left to some of the issues that he's
been accused of ignoring things like
social issues
that's the real question in fact i've
been talking with students as well like
with friends and colleagues over the
last two weeks some were claiming that
he was coming from the left that in fact
he ruled with the support of the right
because he needed so and we'd be more
free during his second mandate so if we
maybe go back to social issues
um well i'm not that sure about that
is human nature doesn't seem to be that
that's socially open
at least when you remember some of the
sentences so i wouldn't be surprised we
have the clue officially speaking
cassettes will uh leave his position in
the prime minister yeah the prime
minister within a couple of days and
we'll know exactly what will be the
philosophy of his next mandate because
he will have to choose a new prime
minister and then we have a clear
indication and
well i figure we will be more the
continuity than in a quiet reversal
all right so of course there is still so
much to decide thank you very much
indeed for joining us nicolas from the
sorbonne university and behind me
obviously you can see the eiffel tower
of course and that is where uh emmanuel
macron is holding his celebration this
evening as he uh goes on for another
five years in the elysee back to you
natasha thanks very much indeed natasha
butler there in paris yes indeed
projections are that in the second round
of the french election medal macron wins
58 of the vote marine le pen 42 percent
emmanuel macron wins a second term
at the elysee palace more as the evening
goes on the celebrations for macron
supporters the recriminations and where
we go from here as we approach the
upcoming parliamentary elections now in
france